audiences were hungry for Netflix's new
series on Jeffrey Dahmer but no one
asked what the people involved in the
real life case would think about the
series until now the sheer number of
movies and television series on the
subject indicates that people have a
twisted affection for serial killers
Hollywood has long been cashing in on
the stories of some of Humanity's worst
people and the True Crime boom has only
fanned the flames in the last few years
we've seen two films about the notorious
serial killer Ted Bundy alone extremely
Wicked shockingly evil and vile and no
man of God however when it comes to
television it seems no killer has been
as high profile as Jeffrey Dahmer 2017's
my friend Dahmer looks at the Milwaukee
monster's coming of age and the
documentary series conversations with a
killer the Jeffrey Dahmer tapes recently
debuted on Netflix most recently the
murderer and sex offender is the subject
of Dahmer monster the Jeffrey Dahmer
story The Series has hit a significant
milestone for Netflix quickly surpassing
300 million hours viewed still the
Jeffrey Dahmer story has its share of
critics many of whom are relatives of
Dahmer's victims now those families have
begun to speak out about the divisive
series
the Jeffrey Dahmer story is so much
bigger than than just him despite the
immense popularity of Dahmer monster the
Jeffrey Dahmer story The Series has
received its share of backlash some
headlines were in response to a
production assistant who claimed onset
conditions were traumatizing While
others pushed back against Netflix
initially tagging the series as an lgbtq
story most damning has been the reaction
from the victims families many of whom
have condemned the series for being
re-traumatizing and exploitative in a
piece for Insider Rita Isbell whose
brother Errol Lindsay was murdered by
Dahmer in 1991 denounced Netflix for
failing to reach out to her even though
they recreated her victim's impact
statement in the widely viewed series
ever see my mother have to go through
this again
she said I was never contacted about the
show I feel like Netflix should have
asked if we mind or how we felt about
making it they didn't ask me anything
they just did it Isbell also added quote
it's sad that they're just making money
off of this tragedy that's just greed
Eric Perry Whom The New York Times
described as a relative of the isabels
agreed saying it's re-traumatizing over
and over again and for what how many
movies shows documentaries do we need
while series co-creator Ryan Murphy has
a reputation for creating violent and
dark series like American Horror Story
many believe that the series creators
should have taken much more care with
this particular story taking into
consideration the real pain and
suffering of the families of Dahmer's
victims Eric Nguyen a former performer
at Club 219 in Milwaukee where Dahmer
frequently visited also criticized the
series existence in an interview with
the New York Times he said it couldn't
be more wrong more ill-timed and it's a
mediocre app for win who personally knew
some of Dahmer's victims the series is
especially disappointing coming from
Creator Ryan Murphy who also created the
inclusive joyful series pose Wynn who is
Black said I was so impressed we finally
had representation that we were involved
in and then he turns around and does
this somebody who's actually attacking
the black gay community Murphy
reportedly set out to tell Dahmer's
story with the victims at the center a
point which actors on the show
emphasized during media appearances star
Evan Peters described the series to
Netflix queue by saying it's how society
and our system failed to stop him
multiple times because of racism and
homophobia everybody gets their side of
the story told but for at least some of
the victims families the series failed
to meet that goal of Dahmer's years-long
reign of terror over the queer community
and Milwaukee win said that's a scar on
our city but for some of those closest
to the
it's a wound that still hasn't healed